okay so we're finishing up the end of we
spent weekend classic figure in the
anthology and now again this guy WT
across we're just doing one class
session in part because his theory isn't
as complicated without reading as much
of than just we did he wrote a book
called the right at the good world in
reading one yeah
we're reading the chapter that tends to
get the most attention and probably has
the most interesting ideas I'm not going
to tell you too much about this guy
looks sort of a typical professors life
in 20th century early 20th century
thinker he wrote his dissertation on the
top so he really took seriously but he's
also known if you go any further into to
philosophy stuff he's known as being the
Ariston scholar and I think that's kind
of revealing because what do you see
going on here this will make more sense
later the semester we're going to look
at aristotle ross is effectively taking
conte and Aristotle day on ecology and
virtue ethics and he's trying to put
them together and come up with the best
parts of each what he's doing is
actually a bit more de ontology than
bridge madness which is why we're doing
it here
but some of the themes that are coming
up I think you've seen already and
you're gonna see again with Arizona
he's also reacting against some of the
moral theories that were really
prevalent at his time you guys have seen
this a few times in the semester to
those
Bentham tackle different moral theories
middle did that as well in the last pass
different moral theories that countless
criticizing so it's not just putting
forth one's own moral theory what I also
asked to engage other more theories and
say here's where they go wrong the ones
that he's doing that with the most are
some of the ones we'll be learning with
debts and egoism hedonism
utilitarianism and then one that it's a
variety of utilitarianism that we did
look at G Wars ideal utilitarianism why
does why is Ross concerned about these
two main reasons one of this these were
very prevalent and it's in his time and
they're also very prevalent in moral
theory in our time if you open up a
business ethics textbook for example you
will definitely see egoism disgust and
you will definitely see utilitarianism
and those will probably get the most
attention and then you'll see some
discussion about the ontology and maybe
see some stuff about virtue ethics or
ethics of care if you're in a Catholic
school you'll see something of natural
law if you know some other suppose you
might see something about you know other
religious ideas and ethics but for the
most part it's gonna be eco ism
utilitarianism and then a nod to date
ology and virtue of this that's because
egoism and utilitarianism are two of the
most common approaches not only in our
time but also in Ross's time and Ross
thinks that there's something is taking
about them so that's a good place for us
to start this is something that he also
thinks a little bit so let's think for a
minute about these different theories
that are all a little bit closely
connected the egoism hedonism
utilitarianism what does the ISM saying
you ought to do what's the right thing
to do is solve interest and in what
sense what
we should pick the action that doesn't
walk for self-interest that fits
yourself in mr. will reassign fulfills
your self-interest if you have two
different options and they both satisfy
your interests to some degree how do you
decide between them you look at which
one's satisfied is you interested most
right so if I'm a real jerk professor I
really like humiliating students I get a
charge out of that and yet I also will
make a really bad guy I also want to
squeeze that student for a crime and
humiliating that was going to interfere
with getting that bribe
which do I want more and which satisfies
my interest more particularly moral
dilemma faced by bad people well it
would be the one that's whichever one I
find satisfies my self-interest to the
policy right so what I'm doing is that
maximizing something if on the other
hand you really enjoy helping people and
you've got two different charities you
could contribute to which one would
actually make you happier to contribute
to that being ego is thing as well pick
what maximizes your happiness and if
satisfies what about hedonism
what's what's that adding it to the next
or what's that what's that narrowing
things to pleasure right so and you can
assume is about nationalizing your
pleasure to us but it's not just about
pleasure
it does say pleasure is good it's saying
the right action to pursuit of is the
one which will maximize your pleasure so
let's think about friendships now you
have some friends that are less
right we admit to that well what does he
even ISM say you have to do you have to
spend more time with the friends are
more fun and you know less time with the
friends for less fun and if they quit
being fun off together maybe add to the
amount of your circles that would be to
maximize your pleasure
that doesn't mean you have to be
completely selfish I mean yeah making
you feel good makes me feel good you
feel good makes you more likely to do
things that are gonna make me feel good
that's the rational thing to do but it's
all about maximizing something for
itself right how does your toilet area
hasn't change that that's just a bum
pleasure right a pleasure in pain yeah
it's maximize and for like the greatest
good the bigger than most people well
yeah that's that's a big jump there
instead of just caring about myself I
care about everybody and I treat myself
is just one person among others and I
try to do things that are gonna maximize
pleasure for for the greatest amount of
people now in each case what am i doing
I'm maximizing something more you had a
version of utilitarianism where he
didn't just confine it to pleasures that
will talk about goods and generally
should maximize good
that's not really that different and
Ross says is that the way that we
actually think about moral decisions and
what we lots of you do we actually stay
whenever is going to maximize something
is the right thing to do we do that some
cases going do that certain certain
things do we do that across the board is
that the way we generally make our moral
judgments right often we're not even
thinking when you make a promise to
someone do you say to yourself this is
gonna conform to the greatest happiness
principle I'm gonna maximize utility all
around have any of you ever done that
have you started doing I value setting
Bentham and mill well how are you going
to know if it's right if you don't apply
it we don't actually do things that by
doing and Bentham and Bill are saying
you should do that in every case they're
saying this is the way that you decide
what's right and what's wrong
how about the greatest if not the
greatest happiness principle the
categorical imperative I know it's kind
of new to you guys but if you started
working with it every time you get into
a situation you say I should only act on
the maximum I can will at the same time
to be a universal law of nature
once my Maxim let me think this out okay
I've got the maxim can I will it to be a
universal law of nature
it could be universal eyes could I
actually do will you give you an
internalized that process yet instead of
treating like what's interesting so it
universalize it not in the sense of
everybody should put that out of
everybody you know that's a good that
that would actually I think it would
bring in a second formulation because
you could say like here's here's how I
imagine you would use something
incorrect if everyone so you you feel
like being a jerk to something
right so and then you think to yourself
when I talk to my own parents we you
know we capture something like that when
somebody's you know cursing somebody out
or say yeah now what that gets us to is
something that Ross is about moral
intuitions are sort of basic ordinary
what if the magic air is called plane
person view of things we often do in
terms of these proverbs or these these
loss he asked us about promises when we
make a promise
do we think again do we think we're
maximizing utility organizer or
something like that
we don't think anything like that maybe
in a few cases we do but not usually
and if somebody were to make promises
just on that basis you think they were
kind of a frequent you you look at them
and say there's something about making
promises with you that doesn't add up
you know Ross is perfectly fine with
when you're asked why should I keep my
promises that I've made you say because
I've made promises
Ross thinks that there's some sort of
moral bedrock intuitions that's a term
that he uses called ethical intuition
ISM that ordinary decent person is going
to to more or less gift they're not
going to be very articulate and
explaining this but if you asked him why
should i why should I keep this promise
where why should I follow the rules of
the game they look at you and say
because that's what you're supposed to
do that's what one does now could there
be some cases where keeping a promise
would be the wrong thing to do if I
would say when I tell you something but
you have to promise and I've never done
this sort of thing before I'm so excited
about it
first you'd say well being excited about
it there's something really wrong yeah
you know that's what you're doing but
you how many of you would say up I made
a promise I'm not going to say anything
that would be the right thing to do
that's what you tell that person well I
think that being prudent that you don't
you know you know make it a case of
saying this is definitely one of those
cases that Ross told me about yeah or a
good utilitarian I won't keep this
promise because it will result in
greater her you yeah and you want to
keep that to yourself what you're doing
with that person but then you get on the
phone right away don't you yeah as soon
as you get them out of earshot and then
would be doing the right thing
Ross would say there are certain cases
where we should break the promise but
those are the exceptions aren't they
now in those cases where we should break
the promise would you say you have a
duty to the other people is that why
you're breaking that duty to keep the
another duty say not to harm other
people not to allow them to be hurt that
make sense it's not the way you feel
about if you do the Ross says okay
that's good that's that's a good start
if you don't have any of those sort of
feelings you're a psychopath or nowadays
we soulless a sociopath and that's a
problem all right that that is by the
way one problem for the moral intuition
is from that not everybody does in fact
have these intuitions but would you say
that in in a functional society most
people do see things that way they may
not be really expressive with it but you
can rely on other people usually to you
know do the right thing because they
feel like they should do the right thing
so if that's the case then
utilitarianism doesn't really make that
much sense does it except for certain
cases certain types of decisions does
even Kant's theory make that much sense
do you actually apply the categorical
imperative each time or do we have a
bunch of that Rosses we look bunch of
different duties yeah they don't all
boil down to the same thing this would
be an example of what we call pluralists
approaches where you recognize a bunch
of different values or a bunch of
different duties and there may be some
problems coming up with them and they
can flick with each other but you can at
least say these these aren't all the
same thing and you have to be able to
person to do the right
should recognize all of us and that's
that's what the other thing that I want
to bring out before we actually look at
each one of these duties Watts says that
utilitarian I think the supplies to the
conching - they're looking at how you
ought to place yourself in relation to
other people and we do have some very
general duties right I think before I
actually came into this classroom and I
was just walking around on Maris campus
and you didn't realize that I was your
professor for this semester as we're
crossing paths you would probably still
feel you had certain duties for his
being just as a human being would you
none of you came up to me getting a good
puncher you know took my wallet and if
you were tempted to do so you'd probably
say if I should do that sort of thing
quit thinking about that right if I said
hello to you you know even though you
didn't know he most likely had this
canvas you promised us a little back
because that's
expectations makes it a nicer place to
say hello
for the hell are you that's that's not
right so what's your answer in a
relationship relationships with people
do you have certain duties that come
from those relationships I'm not sure
you were born fulfill your duties to
your parents all right are you
maximizing utility or something like I
mean you know if you think about it Roth
says dude these are actually very
personal we have some impersonal duties
that way right but most part duties that
we feel that our ordinary life are very
personal they're my duty to this person
and it's in a relationship that's
developed over time or quick of
different ways depending on what we do
at this point so each one of you is my
my students right and I have a son a
very deep personal relationship but I
have a personal relationship with each
one I have certain duties towards you
likewise you have several different
professors right words you have duties
towards each other I think some of it
for a little classmates one of your
classmates is sick and he asks you if
you'll take notes for them would you do
it every person for themselves screw you
after you you say yes I'll take notes
for you you go can another personal
obligation it's not just well I said to
somebody that I would take notes for
them I said to this person I all of that
some and he talks about a bunch of
different relation
promising a promising creditor to deafen
wife to husband the child's parent
friend a friend a fellow countryman a
fellow countryman and different duties
arise from these he says these are
perfectly what make us who we are so if
you think in getting back to that
McIntyre if you read at the beginning of
the semester your narrative is in part a
story about how well you did or how
poorly you did or the mix of both in
recognizing the duties that you had
other people in fulfilling those duties
and also the other way how well they
recognize their duties to you and
fulfill those duties to you that's part
of what makes you who you are you
probably never thought about it that way
but that's that's an important part of
makes that's important part of what
makes you that person who you are
somebody who's not replaceable by
somebody else's story that you're still
on hold
so now after waxing poetic oh yeah
that's what it's one of these duties he
calls these prima facie dues are you
familiar with this term prima fire
yeah you think they'll be coming from
the watcher right say yeah first-rate
well if it's something more like at
first blush or at first glance he's not
saying that these are absolute duties he
said these are the things that without
thinking that much about recognized as
types of duties generally we have these
things as duties if you talk about a
prima facie case you mean a case that is
made without going into everything in
total depth of detail but just looking
at the surface
Sasha Sasha if your skin is coming from
the same turn so he says what we can
distinguish a bunch of these and let's
go through each each one he says you
have duties with fidelity ross is a
classic scholars when we talk about
fidelity the paradigm it is making a
promise when you make a promise to
another person you may not have thought
of it in terms of getting faithful
fidelity is coming from but when you
make a promise you a sense that you need
to keep that promise
right and that's once you've fulfilled
your promise something has been lifted
from something has been done that walks
begun promises where do you feel that
that don't mean anything words our words
are
whereas Catullus says one of his poems
my a woman swears nation's my woman
squares to me she have me a buck Joe if
you saw her write women's words women's
words in love to men wind and running
water you could reverse it very easily
for many women couldn't you yeah neither
is that somehow fidelity doesn't matter
the promises don't mean who is that how
you feel about it if somebody makes a
promise to you and they don't keep the
promise how do you feel sad all these
just happen
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's a sort of
sense of righteous indignation in other
words if I see somebody any other side
yeah
cheating I think falls under this as
well cheating youtuber thing in terms of
life relationships right we can also
think about games Ross says that when
you make a promise or when you enter
into a situation there's an implicit
promise or you engage in an action
promise then you're bound by some duty
of fidelity so you know you start
playing Scrabble with somebody all you
played Scrabble before right probably
really what are some other rules that
you probably didn't actually like look
at the set of rules right you started
playing ceramic and then somebody break
the rules and then somebody else will
column ah where's the rules just make
stuff up you know kids put the Q here
because that's the triple letter score
then use the also the only time which is
funny because I unfortunately take
advantage of
it's only only if somebody else
challenges your word rules about process
works and procedures he is reaching to
the bagging and like flip letters until
you get the ones you want know there's
supposed to be like a tell if it's a
chance to it and you know if you sit
down at the Scrabble board and you get
out that little tray if you start
loading it up with those seven letters
you're not you're not actually looking
across the board and saying the person I
promised you I will follow all the rules
I promised you as well I will follow all
the rules of contract you're making an
occlusive promise though all right and
if you don't follow the rules they're
gonna call you or you don't say you
don't follow the rules about how to
follow the rules somebody challenges you
and it turns out your word isn't really
a word so you know cue an accent
put together you say well we're gonna
stick with this time that would be
breaking up kind of the implicit
contract or the promise right Ross has
this great example of if you're gonna
write a book and you're gonna say that
it's nonfiction you actually have a duty
to make sure that the facts in it are
actually true you know if I were to
write a book about the president of the
college yeah who I don't know all I know
is he's been here for a very long time
and he's considered to be a good guy and
to improve the college let's say I read
a book about it and I say the history of
Dentistry was mermaid born in 1856 from
a mermaid off the coast of Spain it
sounds pretty good right it's a nice
story but if I'm gonna pass that off as
true I'm breaking up and plus a promise
to the reader
okay so there's a lot of different
duties of fidelity when you enter into a
relationship
the person this this is where a lot of
fights come up because it's easy to say
okay you know you have wedding vows and
they comprise exactly this but then how
how far did they extend you know we've
looked at that example before are you
you have a duty to disclose information
about previous partners that you may
still be interacting with that might
fall under this you know if your spouse
or significant other gets attitude if
you didn't say that you're your old
boyfriend I drove from happens to be the
same workplace as you the air probably
angry with you on this this ground they
feel that something has not been done
that should be done that you had
undertaken to do the next one was really
interesting reparation I've mentioned
this before a couple times during the
semester ethics is not just about what
you want to do about honor you know set
up your life just right so that you
realize you're good it's about figuring
out what to do action or to screwed up
because by the time that you come into
this classroom but certainly by the time
that you're my age and you started
thinking about these things you made
some bad decisions you've hurt some
people
you've gone off the track at some times
and hopefully come back you know but
maybe not entirely there are certain
actions that we do that hurt other
people and those impose on us a duty of
reparation of you do as we say making it
right what would be so making examples
there were some of those actions will be
some things that think about your
experience things you either you've done
you've seen somebody do or something
good to you and you felt somebody should
make something
yes like fidelity achieving like I've
seen one of my friends she and like I
know his girl like I've just met his
girlfriend this year and like Oh she'll
ask me and I don't want to get in their
business like I sit back there locates
out of like you need to do something
about this and you can't you can't be
doing this sarah fili yeah we'll come
back when she when you see somebody
cheating you think they there are
certain things they go out and do just
I'm not going to do it anymore
take me back yeah I don't think it's a
preparation and kind of came up in one
application assignment where the person
the other person is indelibly yeah so
what are you preparing by telling her
doing okay I don't know how to describe
the person they speaking hypothetically
hypothetically you're not the other
person doesn't know they're not upset
you're not you're not
yeah but they will be at once one less
detail for this book questioning becomes
we have a new development once once
you've actually told them now let's say
there let's say somebody you're your
best friend comes to with advice they've
just screwed up their marriage either
they told their spouse because they
finally felt guilty enough that they had
to or they got caught you know and now
they had to fess up to it what should
they do they should obviously say it's
not going to happen again but is that
enough what other sorts of things should
they do
once you hurt so I think once you've
hurt someone who's so bad in that idea
like you needs that person just
especially if that person is not by each
other for separately
cheat on them nobody no you're not gonna
do it again like even though you say
yeah I think actions to rebuild lost
trust say if you even get the chance to
repay they might just end it yeah that's
that's truth to them that brings up an
interesting idea do duties away go
further and make sure the relationship
continues even if they don't want it to
commitment so you can't read and write
probably blossoms in a few days so there
may be some cases where you just can't
yeah other people aren't like you it's
unlikely practically speaking than
somebody's in that situation would
actually do that but that's actually a
great suggestion it's almost like
wearing
I'm the exception you know don't
distrust all other better yeah that's a
good there's a lot of them kinds of harm
that we can play some of them are not
quite so it's with people if I wreck
your car
I should replace your car right maybe if
you need to get somewhere to drive your
own until your two new a new car
some of the some of the discussions
about in criminal justice talk about
this and I think that would fit in with
this restorative justice which I'm not
that based because I think it tends to
think of discussions about attentively
other kinds of justice is this idea that
the best thing to do with crimes is not
you know punish people or things like
that to try to restore the relationship
between the offender and people that
they've offended against for society and
sometimes this leads to things like
murderers actually meeting the people
who are related to the person with a
murder and saying that they're sorry
brings about some sort of clover again
my reservation I think that could fit
reparation what about what other people
do good thanks to us there they engage
in actions that benefit us Roth says we
have duties of gratitude he's not
talking about the feeling - he's not
talking about feeling grateful he's
talking about actually doing the things
that display gratitude which you know
first off not spurring over the person
can just benefit certainly taking
advantage of them in any way if they've
made themselves open to you by helping
you would definitely go against that
Duty but you know there's some positive
things as well what should we do with
people if they get into a situation
where we can benefit them should we give
them a sort of preference so long as it
doesn't interfere with say injustice
without technology
I try and use when they step around you
bribe me but if you take down to dinner
do we feel like I am now have an
obligation to take you out to dinner
sometime
how do you feel about somebody who just
you know rides along for all the dinners
yeah there are freeloaders yeah free
water is so mute is not grateful for
what there is like like showing them
gratitude for something they did for you
could that be considered reparation no
reparation is when you've done something
wrong now let's say there they did
something wrong they apologized to you
you say thank you for you know finally
apologized but Ron says something more
mine somebody does something good yeah
now is that referring to somebody that
is doing something good for you out of
their duty it's something good for you
they're doing it just because they want
it it could be it could be either the
parents are good some parents there's
like you know let's say we take to
complete extremes parents would actually
do what they're supposed to do so we
leave other bad parents there's some
parents who like it are so thrilled with
their kids all the time you know kids
are they're so amazing actions all
constantly and they do what they're
supposed to do
drop to the Boy Scout Girl Scout
meetings paint the room that color the
kid wants and then there's the sort of
other extreme of can't stand my kids but
I can't believe that came from me
because look how different they are but
I'm gonna do the right thing by them I
think that's a good but it's better to
do what you're supposed to do not to do
it
then there's the parents who say screw
my kids I'm to do it right want you're
there for me you know you're here with
your chores that's not good
so the Grays viewers probably fit in
somewhere on that continuum right and
actually once you become parents you
will realize that it's very difficult to
have the feeling of affection for your
kids all the time we talk like we do but
you'll realize that you know someday
will be times when they drive you nuts
do you think this is there's something
wrong with this kid but you still have
to behave your parents have done stuff
like that for you you have a duty of
gratitude where it's Ross it's hard duty
- satisfied - I mean they've been doing
stuff for you a long long time and
they'll be doing stuff for you for a
while war I'm guessing and when will you
start like reciprocating on the level
they've done for you you may not even be
able to do them
yeah I was just about to say oh by the
way we may not even watch you too much
yeah I feel like I mean there's gonna be
problem with what I say but by doing the
same thing for the kids that you have
mmm but then was uh people that don't
have is you know but I feel like the
only way I could repay my parents is to
be just as good as the parents they were
that's an interesting idea that maybe
some of the duties of gratitude could be
met by doing something good for another
person yeah that's that's possible it's
interesting to you because some parents
who say I want you to be successful some
of them will say things like I just want
you to be happy you know dick pic this
major that is probably not going to be
financially lucrative but I want you to
study it because knowledge is good I
have a sort of interesting example that
came up recently that showed me
different my sentiments about gratitude
I don't really rate Thank You those I'll
say thank you to the person the person
to call them up and I do that usually
you know at the time I don't come from a
family that sends my mom tried to get us
to do that with our kids the different
sticking partner she didn't really do it
and we serve
but it kind of went against the grain
for me because I felt like my duties of
gratitude was satisfied that my actually
saying thank you let's see if I did the
person a good turn hello my wife feels
guilty if we don't send a thank-you
because she was raised in a family where
you actually do something I guess that's
really the right thing to do this when
I'm done thank you how it's myself I
feel kind of happy if you guys got thank
you you like getting to make me feel
like the person that's done what they
ought to do any of you feel upset when
somebody doesn't send you thank you
would there be some situations where if
a person didn't I don't find myself
simply say it was like a family member
and I went above my sister just like she
would I first she wasn't anything used
for certain things and like not even
like money value but like time diamonds
makes sense
yeah and roots actually looks like
especially actually I've seen it many
times but I feel like there are some
things that aren't really necessary for
oh thank you like my sister
and right now brother-in-law sent me a
thank-you card for like being at their
wedding and being the party of stuff
like that
they really just happy to because it's
my sister you know I was going to be
very - that's true I mean I was thinking
actually you sent a gift at wedding
that's protocol that they should send a
thank-you that's good I don't
necessarily think like a note is
necessary but the manner in which the
person says thank you to you does it
sound genuine are they were is there
really some gratitude there or they just
saying hey thank you you do this again
for me next time kind of deal you know
anything so it's just that has an effect
on it I think you're right in our case I
can tell how important thank-you notes
were for my wife because she felt guilty
about not getting way interested and we
did this sort of typical thing where she
wrote out the whole thing and then sit
here silence
I remember I remember going through
something like stacks over thousand
people showed up to her because she was
unfortunately
okay let's move on justice now when when
we think about justice Ross says often
times we think of what we owe to other
people and so some of the flirting
comprised infidelity to make a promise
contract that's fidelity reparation
that's that's also if you screw things
up if you have a strong sense of justice
you will try to fix things but what else
includes what's us included in justice
fairness apportioning things as he says
equally or according to the merit so if
I order pizzas for the class which I do
but if I were to order pizzas for the
class and I would say okay everybody in
the front row gets three slices two
slices
we couldn't do that but you know I would
if I was going to do something like that
there are these dinners they've been
going out for a while there's there's
three options you pay in like a light
box or kind of box yeah it's like first
world country second like chicken too
like chicken and rice to a big part of a
hill like right so you write some mean
then just say grace yeah and my mom used
to do these all the time and the idea
behind it it's supposed to give you a
sense of how things are actually
proportion so it inform your sense of
justice if you realize that that's what
it's like in the world that maybe say
wow there's something wrong with this I
don't like being you know almost
everybody gets the two or three so I
don't like being on the beans and rice
or just rice maybe I should do something
for fixes yeah what if you had given
Pete said everybody but everybody in the
back row
really hungry and I stole these well you
might be satisfying you might be trying
to sort of you know set things right as
far as his parents also say it's a good
question I mean let me put that one on
awkward so when it comes to justice and
he has to deal with how we how we
distribute things it doesn't always if
you know one of you makes a cake I don't
expect that I should get exactly the
same amount of that cake as you did did
you put the work into it right but if
you bring the cake in the classroom you
would say well if I later on in the
semester bring bring cookies and I said
everybody except for you get a good I
think not only you would be bothered by
that I think all the rest of you right
you would say that justice has been
insulated then there's beneficence and
this is where we go beyond justice
beneficence this song is a set of duties
that we have towards other beings by the
sheer fact that we can benefit and Ross
thinks about benefits in three main ways
he thinks about Fletcher we're doing all
the time right
you know we would say if I can't
yeah actually the shelter
I think he really is
once talks about two other news virtue
and knowledge and you can benefit a
person by making them smarter by making
them better than form that's different
than the pleasure right oftentimes the
process of learning is not particularly
pleasurable then afterwards you've
acquired something I think all of you
have classes where you took the class
you didn't enjoy the class at the time
you came out of it and then the semester
later you found yourself using stuff
from in your life man that was really
useful for me to go through that class I
have really got a lot of which I
actually put more into it so I got more
making somebody a better person helping
them towards you know being integrated
towards having the virtues towards being
able to settle their moral dilemmas that
are going to come up that's helping them
this book again is that necessarily
particularly pleasurable sometimes that
means actually giving people displeasure
you know if your friend there's somebody
who you admire excessive hey you're
screwing up you get better knock that
off
does that make you happy when they say
stuff like that to you not unless you're
a masochist but they may be benefiting
you as a result can you think of people
who have over the course of your life
set you straight
painfully and later on you recognized
I'm glad that person was there
yeah they kind of did the same thing I
did when I was younger and they learned
but my parents always said like the
whole thing is when I was in high school
I hated having like such like a
particular curd for you like all my
friends ever like it's a curse yeah
all my friends are allowed out first
it's like second reason and then again
when you're organized I was like
seriously you had me for a reason yeah
yeah I think that's a that's a great
classic example so they they benefited
they made and they also probably by
making you stick to a curfew they
instilled in you this we're a
disposition to pay attention to time and
to think about consequences and those
are those are important really before
class we're talking about is it better
to give your kids in irrational overly
strict sort of moral code to live by or
just to say how would ever you like you
know live it by the live in some ways
it's better to give them some crazy
strict you know may screw them up a bit
moral code because then they've got
something they can react against first
off not this sort of
and the who knows what anything means
kind of relativism but you also instill
in them certain habits if there's some
sort of moral code in plates and it's a
crazy moral code these get the kids used
to the idea of having to give some sort
of justification for what they want to
do the example that I gave is imagine
imagine how powerful were to say this is
a biblical household we're gonna do
exactly what the Bible says and nothing
else the kids you know they get this big
document which is like you know a whole
bunch of different types not just books
with different types of literature and
they're supposed to live according to
this well you have that sort of thing
that I got you'll get pretty good at
like looking through it and finding the
verses that conform to what it is if you
think you want to do or what should
happen in the situation which by itself
is not necessarily good a little reading
it's good and then you'll also get
really good at making a case why should
this particular the principle apply here
mom or dad and if they've done that
that's actually benefited you you
probably don't want to just stick with
whatever your Bible you probably won't
have some moral principles that are not
just whatever happens to be on page 86
or page 516 but that would be a good
habit to have that habit of being able
to make a case with them that would be a
benefit whereas if they said do whatever
you like how do kids like that turn out
you ever have any friends like that
every it was really fun going over to
their house because there were going to
be rules are those friends shooting as
well now your experience maybe no
solvent improvement is really
interesting it's time to do business if
you want to be good to other people you
also want to be good to yourself did
you're a person too and do you need to
like really pay close attention and give
yourself pleasure to make your life
better that way do you have to work to
make yourself a better person morally or
intellectually yeah that takes some
doing right you if you feel like you're
not doing what you want to do with
respect to your moral life or with
respect to your intellectual life you
are running into this duty of self
improvement we don't have to tell
ourselves go have a good time we already
go on to do that we already have a sort
of natural drive for them but to improve
ourselves to make a make ourselves make
our condition better with respect to
what like for instance let's say you
have decided that you have a character
flaw now is bothering you
to do that would be filling the studio
song improvement or if you look at your
relationships that here said man all my
friends are dummies
I shouldn't hang around with these like
I should find some smart people who will
actually you know lead me into doing
other things that say just sitting
around talking about whatever yeah
I need somebody to actually get a
challenge you would be carrying out a
process of self-improvement legit dude
then we come to the last one
non-maleficence which is basically that
means just not dating her that's
different things than benefit you also
feel that you have a duty not to hurt me
right when you do harm people do you
feel bad you not only feel that you
ought to try to make up for it when you
also feel you shouldn't have done first
place second form to your experience
yeah I think you actually somebody turn
me mad at somebody
yeah yeah and that would get Cuse for
one of the other virtues duties would
supersede that you also have a
responsibility to keep yourself from
being harmed so if we're doing the self
defense you know you didn't even think
for example cases where you find
yourself having to do something
it could be physical and you find
yourself afterwards feeling kind of a
out about it even though you knew that
you had to protect yourself so I wish I
didn't have to hurt that person that
would be recognizing this this Duty so
all of these are our duties that we feel
they don't all reduce to want that they
don't I'll boil down to one single
principle for Ross
let's say some kid gets bullied and the
teacher doesn't
the management's like a K through 12
that's really kind of so maybe
elementary school all the kids are
picking out this one kid and you know
maybe you've got thirty five kids in
your classroom
can you imagine that that's what Chicago
piano morning you know but you're not a
lot of this gets to you can you like say
certain so it's kind of tough to handle
bullies and you don't know kids are like
I think is logged in on the good end and
probably also these sort of situations
right so some kid is bullying and it
starts affecting their ability to
concentrate to do well in taxes and the
grade is based on largely on their tests
and this semester classes or any of you
yeah so that you know and the semester
test not the way to set up a class right
you can that was that but this class
does not place everything and all the
grading in the last you know two weeks
of the class cuz that's a bad pedagogy
for practice what is this teaching
tonight so this kid flunks the test was
kid was being bored you know you have a
requirement to treat everybody fairly
maybe that kitchen swapped the class
though but this other duty of reparation
could impinge on that teacher that do
what he or she was supposed to do and
making sure that this kid could drive
yes maybe they have a duty done to make
it up to the kid by cutting them some
slack is this all possible
you know
oh yeah yeah my house kids who get cast
on through these systems that we have
that's true that's worth thinking about
as well you notice the way that it works
for Ross is we sort of throw things on
the table when we start thinking what
about this what about this what about
this this is the way that Ross thinks we
actually do Campo moral issues
oh yeah definitely I would say to have
their - to justice to be
what's really nothing that's solution
but you know reparation I always has to
be done when we cause that you screwed
up we didn't find the best solution yeah
I'm not saying the little kids shouldn't
get the second chance but if you do that
then for the sake that he's been bullied
that what if there's other things that
other students have had problems what if
they never came you know it's just
there's always going to be other so they
might say about me yeah my parents are
divorcing well yeah then it just sets
precedent for if you have a special it's
kind of like the application thing that
you said like they were having family
issues so do you let them you knew that
she cheated on the test yeah so yeah she
had family issues but what if a student
was having family issues and didn't say
anything yeah it's always like everyone
has something that they could what was
interesting about that particular
assignment was that some of you had some
pretty good suggestions for how the
professor
they said well he could cover some swag
but only so much slack and figure out
where to draw the line but that does
seem to be a matter justice
like some of these suggested getting the
student to see for the semester having
the student come in and talking with the
student about using it as like an
opportunity to talk about what's first
of all what's going on if you you know
the personal stuff others are really
smart it's not a suggestion
some people say just stay with the you
know helping a student flunks or just
let it slide but a lot of you found some
sort of middle ground
I've been if we were using Ross is
what's exactly what we would do notice
we've probably heard from about six
students that say on this particular
example isn't it better that you have a
lot of different voices at the table
making one person speaking up for
fidelity another person speaking up for
justice because we often if we're on our
own we we don't realize all difference
how do we deal with a complex on that
arise because that's going to be a
problem you know one is one duty seems
to contradict another base as well
there's no hard and fast rules for that
you have to look at the actual
individual situation and then you have
to sort of figure out which one is more
appropriate or which ones are more
appropriate Ross has a couple different
things I just want to go through very
clearly he says that I would sign
indeterminate situations you're not
going to be able to figure out
necessarily how would you do you ought
to be happy how far you ought to go with
Operation Gratitude
it's not possible to provide cover he
also says that that any one of these two
people were written by another dude so
maybe let's say we take the example of
promise again the promise with the
bottom right there's a duty to prevent
harm to other people that supersedes the
duty to keep your promise in that case
does that mean that this this always
supersedes that that doesn't mean that
it means you actually have to judge in
that situation you have to think it
through the other thing that he says is
we can't say that some of these duties
are a bit more pronounced and this one
is probably the most important of the
deuce so before you have to decide
whether to do justice or to benefit
people you should at least make sure
you're not hurting other people so if I
can make you happy by taking stuff away
her making happy would be beneficence
but I shouldn't take stuff away so
there's certain kind
since that I shouldn't do right
she says that fidelity reparation is
gratitude these three right here have a
certain greater stringency that's the
word he uses or he might say strictness
than the others but again it doesn't
completely supers but in general he
would say look if you've made a promise
to somebody that comes before other
things so if I in order to break my
promise I do so because it will benefit
you I shouldn't do that
or you know making up for long things
showing gratitude action that shouldn't
be me
I shouldn't sacrifice those to the
Nemesis for a song but again these these
whose gentle me have an absolute one
single way of figuring out what's the
deal on justice and what's his view on
justice and the predominance of that or
the other things I mean well it's hard
to say it sounds from some of the things
that he says as if justice certainly
takes priority over beneficence you can
think of it this way with respect to
justice and in essence first you you set
things out fairly and then if you've got
left over
but you can do about it obviously money
with anytime a faction so the Justice is
all about appropriation of things
appropriation like questioning
yeah right how you spread them out so it
could extend to a lot of things it has
to do it how we distribute benefits and
costs in society how we treat each other
in the workplace how we treat each other
in terms of friends or families all
those cookies just the reason why I
mentioned it is if you've got the
promise like how we mentioned earlier
and you have to break it because you
know the idea of degree they're good
yeah then I mean there's an injustice
overtake fidelity yeah there could be
some cases where keep a promise that's
been made previously would would bring
about injustice and actually I'm gonna
read something that that Ross says he
says
he says these seem to be in principle
all the ways in which primo flash of
duties arise in actual experience their
component together in a highly complex
way so there could be more than one duty
in play at a time so he says that the
duty of obeying laws of one's country
arises partly from the duty of gratitude
for the benefits one was received from
him currently from fidelity an implicit
promise to obey there seems to be
involved in permanent residence and then
he also talks about how justice and
reparation into tied together
you think if our society were pretty
good actually when it comes to like
historic and justices a lot of them that
were around or you know not certainly
not as prevalent some of them have been
very well addressed well let's say
you've got a society in which some group
of people are clearly a short ugly stick
they've been on the short end for a long
time and it puts them at a disadvantage
Rojas would say that there's both of
Duty of justice to set things right and
to level the playing field to say
everybody gets the same benefits
everybody gets the same opportunities
but then there's the other further duty
of reparation to make up for it in some
way to try to fix things to try to
redress the harm they've done and this
is probably one of those cases were
thinking about historically
discriminated against groups we would be
thinking about cases in which I forget
people brought it up
there would be this possibility
satisfying the duty for reparation not
for the people who are originally hardly
but for other people later not so Ross
talks about how these all can get
reactive in complex ways one other thing
that I want to stress before we BN
so far he's just talking about what's
what's right and Ross says you don't
actually have to have a motivation for
this sort of thing to do the right thing
that's not yet being morally good so for
example gratitude you don't have to have
the feeling of gratitude you satisfy the
duty of gratitude by doing certain
things or like reparation you don't
actually have to feel sorry but you have
to you have to do the things that
somebody who is sorry with you and if
you do that then you're doing the right
thing
that doesn't yet make your act more than
good what makes you happy morally good
is the motivation for instance keeping a
promise Rick because you you know you
recognize that's the right thing to do
that's what that's a right cap keeping a
promise because you want to be the kind
of person who keeps promises
that's a morally good thing to do
keeping a promise because you recognize
that you have a relationship with this
other person and you care about that
other person
I suspect that loss would say that's
more good as well so this is just sort
of the starter this tells us what our
duties are it doesn't get get us to the
highest end which is being more or less
a person but at least you know somebody
who's doing their deeds they're good in
the sense that they're doing the right
thing it's much better
what do you guys think of us many years
with death a lot of immoral theories
we'll come back there's a lot of
when you're in the moment you're
deciding which one of these things
yeah whatever
so we've got two things the flexibility
that it's attractive because we do it
the rest of you I think when you look at
these on the board you can like kind of
if you look at them you can see what
ones you usually tend to like go with so
it's kind of interesting if you're like
talking about a situation you usually I
feel like people usually steer toward
certain yeah let's say we so if we
accept that boss is basically writing
these these cover and which do people
tend to steer towards if you knew that
then you would also know which ones are
your weak ones and I think it depends on
your personality like anyone I think
you're right the personality type like I
know that for me I'm much more motivated
by fidelity and justice
reparation gratitude there might be
someone who like only wants to benefit
other people therefore they like throw
away their own self-improvement yeah
that's right being just themselves I
don't know it's like I'll go stand in
there yeah I think there is one
personality type that would be a problem
for this any sort of intuition ISM
associate deaths right because they
don't feel bothered so Ross can't cope
with that but I don't know if that's
actually that bad of criticism I can't
account for people who are not one of
the rest you think these these seem like
good points to the theory or maybe are
their weaknesses
the Petrus maybe you could heard that
Tesla beast or the laying out what are
your favorites another thing that we can
of interesting I'll leave it this it's
quick to why we need other people you
can have a test like that might it not
be better they actually have somebody
who knows you and of your to give you
that sort of a suspect and say hey I
think watching you you think you're
really good at this but you're actually
not so good at this you are however much
stronger in these than you realized you
were do you think that's where they
could be useful I know
so yeah does this seem more reasonable
is all about reason right could it be
possible to be overly rational I didn't
need to say right you're using more even
when you're using things more reasonable
to apply okay distinction
I think you know this is something that
came up when we talked about Plato yeah
those three parts of the soul Plato said
yeah the appetites gonna show look out
that's always gonna be bad if through
most or the middle part runs us all that
could that could go bad - and he doesn't
say anything about the person who's like
totally dominated by reason and
rationality and the emotions that sounds
like confidence anytime that you're
doing reactive doing the right thing
because you feel like doing that because
that makes you feel good moral theory to
start with but I think he's ironic
because his ideas to make no holes right
yeah so that's why I feel like adding
virtue to the to duty kind of fills up
one of those holes out boys do you think
that these should be understood as
duties or would you understand these to
be maybe something also like virtuous
character traits
yes we'll leave up with them have a good
break